hello everyone and welcome to
kobe smell 19 advances in diagnosis and
clinical management my name is maría
antoineta chávez water marketing manager
and i will be your moderator for
today's event today's educational webinar
is presented by the
aido you network  by the
water molecular division americas scientific affairs team
before we begin i would like to
remind everyone that the event is
interactive we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like and
at any time during the
presentation
to do so simply type your
question  in the up to equation box and
click the send button to send we will
answer as many questions as
we have time by the end of the
presentation
and you are having trouble seeing and hearing the
presentation click the
support tab at the
top right of the
presentation window or let us know about your
problem by clicking on the box
up to question located  on the far
left of the screen
I would now like to introduce to our
presenters today doctor del
nectar and el navarro is a doctor of
medicine and surgery with a specialization and
doctorate in microbiology and
parasitology obtained at the
university of valència he is currently a
professor of microbiology at the
university  from Valencia and head of
service of the Department of Health of the
Valencian Community' Dr. Navarro
will be presenting us with the keys
to the microbiological diagnosis of Kobe
19.
Our second presenter is
Dr. Margaret Al Colmo, she is
a clinical researcher at the reference center.
cruz
oswaldo cruz foundation and is in charge
of tuberculosis treatment research projects and
epidemiological surveillance of
multidrug-resistant tuberculosis. She
is currently a professor of
respiratory medicine at the Pontifical
Catholic University of Rio de Janeiro and a
member of numerous
professional associations  brazilian and
international ales the alcohol doctor
will not be talking to you about the clinical management of
kobe 19 what we have learned for more
information in their biographies visit the
detailed tab
at the top of the screen and
now we leave you with doctor david
nabarro go ahead doctor
Thank you very much for your
presentation call. For me it is a pleasure to be
with you today and to arrive in Latin America
and I will try to make it as synthetic
as possible in a field that evolves day
by day and I am very afraid that some
positive thanks may have
become obsolete.
well everyone probably knows by now
cars 2 is a coronavirus this is a
very large rm love or catenary virus
approximately 30,000 nuclei and that belongs
to the genus is beta coronavirus and that
includes other coronaviruses that
infect humans seasonally or not
seasonal specifically these two
belongs to the sabeco virus subgenus
viruses widespread in nature  uraleza
I just want to specify a couple of things that
are of interest when guessing
some diagnostic keys, take a look at this is
the compared genome of those two sharp
gamers viruses that are quite similar to
each other and at the 5 prime end there are two
or survive frames that  They encode the entire
replicative machinery of the virus. It is
interesting to emphasize this because this
sequence includes the
vidal polymerase and the
classic targets of the pc we use
to
diagnose the disease caused by this virus.
These open green frames are
reasonably well conserved in  In all
the coronaviruses that I have mentioned before,
it is also remarkable the fact that
this genetic fragment of the virus
encodes an ex-nuclear origin that prevents
that virus from mutating or that the
mutations go rather the mutations
that accumulate generate a
lot of variety  say this is a
corrective mechanism therefore the
variation capacity of this virus is
limited if  it is compared with other
viruses
rm ago however not in this way it is raw
there are several bosses among which are
those that code for structural proteins
estepona said everyone with friends it is a
virus with a membrane and in the membrane
we find several complexes group by
take 2 all  It is relevant the protein is
the first that is the function is
international with its receptor then the
m protein
likewise the efe protein all of them
afternoons of some kind you are rich
we use all diagnosis of kobe 19 and
inwardly we find the
n protein that make up the nucleus
capsid that in turn on earth the rn a
viral the 3 prime end of these viruses
is more variable and more variation in these
sequences between the different corona
viruses that infect humans
well clearly classically rather
cell culture is considered the
method  diagnosis of references of the
certain thing is that practically nobody
does it of routine form because the
culture that does not  It is particularly
complicated, it requires the use
of type 3 biosafety cabinet devices or
cell culture, it is not a
particularly sensitive method, although
we understand that when we do not detect
viruses in the upper respiratory tract
by culturing a patient, I say that
we understand that this patient is
probably no no  contagions or the
practical reference diagnostic test on a day-to-day basis is the pc
efe. In fact, several
generations of rt pcr have followed one another and we continue to use
realtime techniques with some frequency, prior extraction is required
and then amplification and detection of
the  hosts in a second phase of
the reaction these special ones in
real time that usually take
between 2 and 5 hours to run but we already have
faster tests which are the tests
that can potentially be used
at patient care points
some of them
combining extraction amplification  and
detection can generate results in
approx.  you an hour even less
in some cases
many times it is a very large number
of fish that have been approved by
regulatory bodies by fedea in the usa
by court in the european union
those ppr have one or more targets
especially in sgm
several gene sequences that  it encodes
the protein motorcycle also the
cold polymerase told you before and
original and box is also a target of
some kind of zoo less
frequently
classically it has been said that to
validate the positive result it is
necessary to amplify two targets at least
well this is orthodox but in
moments in which we have had great
difficulties to issue results in a
timely manner because we have settled
for simply diagnosing the
disease through the amplification
of a single target but what is
orthodox I insist on
detecting at least two targets to
consider that the patient is kobe
positive
these are some questions that I want to
answer all species have the
most  same benefits than information
provided to the context 7 where
we can delay two how long does it
mean the same to detect rn a by pcr
than the virus by culture what is
the prognostic implication of the
life load in different compartments what
happens with the repos and tives of rm to what
The fish generate problems for us and then
very briefly when
slurry strategies should be used, which, as
you know, allows us to save
the asset, which has not been a bad thing
during
all tribal species.
Deportations The answer is clearly
this is a study.  This
is a study that includes 13
well-characterized samples that, as you can see young
in the graph, not all of these
commercial species that the others evaluate are
capable of detecting the virus
and that basically has to
do with the fact that these species
have  Different mini detection tests
can vary even a base
10 logarithm with a general character.  to which there are only
some of those that are carried out in
general, we can say that the
classic real-time species by
calls like this are slightly more
sensitive than the point of care tests
but this can necessarily change 4
what does the ct tell us well the cc is
I do not know that
one uses
legal burden quantification standards, the
lower you are, the lower the number of
cycles we need to amplify
Adriana, the greater amount of virus there is in
the sample, but I want to draw
attention to this.  This is very important to me,
people do not always
accurately reflect the virus load in a
given sample. I have in
mind that
many of the commercialized species
do not include a target that indicates the
level of cellularity, therefore the
quality of the sample.
therefore the ct can be very high and
yet if the sample is poorly
cellular the charge is higher than expected.
One estimate by simply looking at the gts is
a work that we recently published
that demonstrates this fact in patients
who were finally positive by pcr
the probability of detecting the virus one
of the targets of the virus in this case was
the gene
in a nasopharyngeal sample was all the
greater  the more cellular the sample was,
in this trial we used as gene k
housekeeping the one that encodes the beta
group bonitas therefore this is a
very relevant fact perhaps we should
have security controls to
make sure that the charges that
we are reporting even though sebastián
action without connectives  it
really adjusts to the one that the patient presents
at a certain moment in a complete sample
where two good ones are detected
virtually everywhere it has been
detected although evidently by its
route of entry we first find it
in the upper respiratory tract if the
patient is able  to clarify the
infection nothing more and also depending
on how it is  activity the infection
through thick drops or aerosols it
is possible to find
simultaneous application in the
upper and lower respiratory tract with a
general family character that tells them that we
found it in the upper tract loses them
the first two weeks
after infection a little more
perhaps  then the virus tends to clear
the upper respiratory tract and is
found if the infection progresses to
touch to -7 inside two points
the virus 50 from the second or
last week frequently in the
feces
although the virus culture from  from
the feces has been reported
anecdotally but this may have
a non-negligible logical component,
the release of the virus
through the feces and then
it can also be found in the blood
, however, recent data seems to
indicate that only this  It occurs in
patients who develop more severe forms.
Note that the presence of the virus in the
head  e is using highly
sensitive closures up to 67% of patients
have
top 20 srs srs in
feces from the second third week
after acquisition of the
infection even seems that the
excretion time of these two in  stool lasts
longer in the upper respiratory tract,
this is very important, how long it
takes for the rm abidal of
the upper respiratory tract to clear up,
well, several studies seem to
indicate that a median of two to
three weeks after the onset
of symptoms or a little  more perhaps
from the moment one acquires the
infection but there are people and this work
illustrates it that, except for the virus in
the upper respiratory tract,
let's say it more precisely, we can
actually find the virus in the
upper respiratory tract for
longer times, look at  this
graph these are data from patients
at 2 from the second week
after quitting  to hospital where
they are not inpatients up to
6.6 percent of patients are
able to actually excrete in
the upper respiratory tract long
after symptoms have ceased
two weeks after
discharge from hospital and this may
continue
In fact, there seems to be a
direct relationship between the time it takes to
clear the virus from the
upper respiratory tract and the severity of the infection,
the time to emergence being
slower, therefore the persistence of rn a
in the upper respiratory tract is longer
lasting in  patients who have
developed more serious forms of
disease
a very important matter I never tire of
tracing this matter which is
somewhat obvious detecting rn ar does not
mean under any circumstances that the
patient is effective one can have in
some compartment and thus
compartment we cannot isolate
infectious virus this
perfectly illustrates a series of  works that
I am going to show you this was probably
the first successful study is led
by cristián rogel in germany in berlin
and what they essentially see is that they
are incapable of culturing viruses
despite the fact that they detect rn a viral
from the eighth day after  the
onset of symptoms is more they
associate the probability of cultivating
virus to a certain load level in
fact below six base
10 logarithms with superficial apcr distort the one
that the cdc used
let's say they recommended offers
below 10 at 6 touches per  my video they are
able to culture the virus they always
do it when the gala charge level
exceeds 6 base logarithms min
they are in this study they
find a relationship between the cti the
probability of culturing the virus in
fact they do not culture the viruses when
the  ct is greater than 24 per 3rd
these were patients with forms of a 9
patients were very few with
key forms but mostly with forms
intermediate in terms of severity of kobe
is a work published by colleagues
from October 12, those cited from Madrid in October
and believes in something discreetly
different, this is what they see is that
things are as described by wolf in the
book 'one hundred in patients who  they develop
non-serious forms of disease
intermediate forms of 19 meters however the
presence of the infective virus can be
delayed somewhat longer in patients up to
34 weeks after the onset
of symptoms in people who have
developed more severe forms
even they are able to culture
virus in  samples whose cep is
using a different fish tank than the one
used by the rating group I insist with
bosses even above 30
particularly in patients I insist that they
have developed serious forms of
diseases the same thing these authors see in this
study that is to say
essentially what I want  mean is that
the probability of detecting
infective virus is indeed correlated
with  on the ct but although the cetes that
provide different tcr are clearly
police we cannot generalize a
taco of people who assure us that we will not be
able or if we will be able to isolate viruses and
cash from a particular sample
of the respiratory tract functions
another matter of interest correlates
the  virus load with the severity of the
infection well it would make sense it would make
sense but I don't have the feeling
that there is enough proof of this
fact it
is difficult to judge it is difficult to
play the data that has been provided in
this regard because most of
the  loads are ingested through cc
and in the special ones that the authors have made,
a housekeeping control has not been included,
therefore there may be a
wide variety, as I said at the beginning
of my exposition,
of sample quality cellularity that can
directly impact on  the actual load estimate
in this
that leads us to the following we must
inform the fish
I am not a party  At this time, I would not be in favor of
informing the sods because proven
practical information cannot be derived
from them, therefore I insist that I
would not be in favor, less for the
moment, perhaps over time, yes, but I
do not think we have sufficient data to
support that we should inform the h3
so there is data, for example, on the
relationship between the virus load in the
blood and the severity of 1,019 this is a
study published very recently in
clinical practice two times in which it seems to be
demonstrated
asuncion these authors use
digital pcr to quantify rn abidal in
plasma they detect in  In
reality, many patients, however, as you can see in the
graph, the amount of the load present in
the systemic compartment is higher
than in very severe patients. In patients
with milder forms of Kobe, this is
data that must necessarily be
contrasted.
What happens with the  repos and tives this
statement what we are seeing more
and more frequently is people who text
positive and  At some point then
the virus apparently cleared up and some time
after two three weeks later
these people if they are given to
upper respiratory taco or can only
find even in the absence of
symptoms which is usual
rn abidal most of these
people have become sansero
converted to a company except those that have
been described so far and in
no case have we been able to isolate
infectious viruses from the
upper respiratory tract of these people and that are
probably not enough
what problems does the fish tank have? Well,
it has several it is not a
perfect test for  We know that
to begin with, the sensitivity of PCR
is not extreme, it is not 100%
, PCR must be used
properly, particularly in patients, in people who are rather asymptomatic.
which
clearly demonstrates what I have just
said if one is infected one day the
probability of detecting the renal  The
virus the day after the
infection is virtually zero and that
percentage is decreasing now, to
put it another way, the probability
that we have the virus is
increasing as the
infection progresses so that the virus is
almost always detectable in
patients with symptoms during the
first 23 days after
symptoms peak is probably therefore
not futile to PCR people who have
been in contact with cases
immediately after being in contact
since the polarity of the
activity fishbowl is virtually  nil the
probability that it is positive I insist
increases gradually as
the infection progresses this is a
very important fact that one has to take
into consideration when designing
mass screening policies with doing
well because the lack of sensitivity
relatives pcr good as  I was saying before there is
some kind of study limit of
detection is manifestly better  orable
manifestly improvable
then one may not use the
correct sample we believe that the
correct thing is to merge aspire forgiveness to its
appearance or more than its white side
vice in the means of transport with the
inhibitors it seems that the had a
second sample and that it advances to
confirm it but the outlet could be a
great substitute for the
nasopharyngeal and wolof alicia sweat aspirator that
generates more discomfort in the patient and of
course in patients who develop
pneumonia to the tractor samples 7 or
less are particularly valuable
sputum if the patient is able to
issue it or else samples obtained
bronchoscope a candle franke of the
most important cause of
negative endorsements is as I have been saying a
bad cell a little plurality of the
sample and also possibly and
I have also said the wrong timing to
take the sample to do later  There are
other analytical project problems that
I don't have time to analyze  but
in general I can say that the ccr
is not a perfect technique but it
is not as bad as we have wanted to
see everything buy it simply you have to
use it to get the most out of it
as it plays when it plays and with
the oil sample
what I was saying  saliva seems a
good substitute for the exudate aspirated in
the safa itself, a much less
traumatic sample to collect even in
this work published in csis mechanics, it
seems that even the ideal loads
in outlets are slightly
higher than in nasopharyngeal sweating, it
is a sample to  take into account
especially in pediatric training and
I think that many times it is one of those we
have on the market that will more than adjust to its
use despite our
graduates with this type of master's degree
the pool strategy is what we have been
using in my  service for some
time when the energy test if we
publish it when the prevalence or
rather the incidence of  the infection is
below 5% I believe that the
bullying strategy we
recommend doing puzzles between 5 and 10
samples before extraction cannot be
done with incidences greater than 10
percent is not a cost benefit but
it is for incidences below the  5%
particularly below 1% and in
the latter 105 their power to pool is
much bigger
[Music]
what about the antigen test
we are probably
excited about this test
because our experience is very
preliminary and still our public
This is how it makes us feel. It seems to be a
very sensitive test, obviously it will not be as
sensitive with PCR as the species, but
it can be very useful in
patient care points,
especially in primary care.
the
positive ones that of course not but hopefully
we will be able to not have to
grow those who are negative
by the third suit when t  We have to
demonstrate that the samples are PCR
positive and antigen negative are
negative cultures and we are working on that. There
is nothing retired yet in relation
to this trial in this regard, but it will soon be
possible if we are able to demonstrate that
if it works that well for them
and others of a similar nature.  Sensitivity and
specificity can be exactly
useful in the control of the tandem that everything
in primary care and in emergencies
explained
very quickly I am going to refer to
geological techniques and measuring erotic techniques are
used for what they are
used for or can be used for what they are used for
They work seems like a priority but that
's how many people forget about this
matter. They practically say waves and they
disappear before the 19th century. Hygiene is good,
indeed the
immune system produces them before the
bosses and one thing is that they appear and
other things  that we are capable of
detecting them, in fact very frequently
we detect either simultaneously gsm
or in  Even pregnant women, therefore,
the presence of genes is not a
sufficiently reliable marker of acute infection.
This is an issue that we must
keep in mind. In this work, what
I have just said is demonstrated. Many people
generate zero simultaneous conversions.
Let me know
what happens with the serological tests.
You know that the 6 rapid ones that
use lateral trick
immunochromatography and then there are tests that are a little more
complex, the ELISA
or breeding tests, defined license,
how these tests work, it is difficult to
generalize,
there is enormous variability in the
quality of these tests, whether they are
rapid tests of the  side group or
cold breeze tests
this study clearly demonstrates what I
'm saying and no two tests are the
same we've had we've used
these tests
during during this
during this pandemic without having
validated them sufficiently
beforehand to begin with these tests
routinely detect very
different antigens between  If with  with formations
different from each other especially that
protein nucleus or even the abilities according to
no s 2 or even the peptide
the pp the reverence
the amino acid sequence that
interacts for sure that interacts
with the receptor to open if the
feeling I have is that we have
used them  Too many invalidated interviews,
so no two tests are
equal to each other. It doesn't work
to say the tests get ready, those
are always better than the quick ones
because it is like that for many tests but
not for all of them. I have seen
quick tests that are better than some.  Of
the ready-bred products that are
marketed,
let's not forget the falsely positive GM and
we have published this,
especially in asymptomatic patients in
low latency scenarios. A
positive hygiene does not necessarily indicate an
acute infection to begin with and is very
often
a false negative.
another thing that interests me not
all geo tests do  logical and not all of them
predict the
neutralizing activity of the soil in the same way and this can
be of great interest when
estimating protection assuming that
we see with the level of
neutralizing antibodies that protect against
reacquisition, not the acquisition of things
when there are vaccines and  yes this not all
not all the lists not every day they
are capable not all side
football tests none like all that
are capable of predicting the level of
neutralizing antibodies present in
the soil we have
recently published and generally or
witness the services  which or pups that
best predict serum authorizing activity
are those whose target
the rbd is the rbd peptide that is
included as I said before the
safety that 1 of the first
that is the best the others all see here
correlation expanded with attitude with
neutralizing antibodies  use
only that 1 or that complete one or that plus m or
even n isolated
it is not easy to integrate  interpret serology
look at what I tell you on this
slide
plastically it says I don't have and management
I don't have and gm is I am protected well
it depends we have seen what
conversions leave in patients who
are still capable of excreting
infective virus or I have and hehe if not  I have and
gms I'm not contagious well, the same thing depends on the
poster I don't have and hehe I don't even have
and gm is I haven't been infected well it's
not safe either we are seeing that
people especially who develop
asymptomatic forms of kobe develop
fleeting antibody responses we
are not capable  fleetingly detect traces
of antibodies even some
never convert even though they have very
cells that we are seeing are
phenomena that are being such as
frequency or physical in the student I
don't have and gm but I don't have I said it is
I just told you  I recently got
infected today and that's a sign, well,
it can't necessarily be a
fake and
people can be  converted than not
having converted that not being
contagious because it is not that it is a virus and
effective in the respiratory tract
for sure therefore I do not have the
feeling that physical decisions have to be made
based on geological results I
say that geology cannot help in
certain cases at the diagnosis of
kobe, particularly in patients who
are negative by pcr as long as
at least a week has elapsed
since the onset of
symptoms, but in general we
should not make decisions based on
geological results obtained
by rapid tests  how much for smooth or
cold, in fact, this is what
our society recommends
in an already old document from
March 30 and that comes to say what I am
saying, they can be auxiliary
to feces in the diagnosis of acute ovi
but it is not the best service  of the
oenological peats for what will be the
logical classes is to do
serological studies will serve  n obviously to
evaluate vaccine responses etc.
they are not tests designed for the
diagnosis of acute infection by cases
and these are the key points in
intervention from my point of view the
pcr is especially low reference
with all its problems with its
limitations it is still a good
test for the diagnosis of code the
positivity of pcr does not
necessarily mean and necessity
the pcr as I have already said can return
false negatives particularly when
one does it too soon or too
late if they use
superior appropriation the diagnostic performance of two
erotic meters is very variable and
only light the judicious use of pcr decides
serological methods allows the design of
public health policies that are
cost benefit that are effective and that
is all thank you very much for your agency
thank you very much doctor david nabarro and
now we continue with the author
margareta el colmo with  his presentation
clinical management of kobe 19 what  Let's see you
later, doctor,
thank you very much for the invitation. It has been
a pleasure to be with David Nabarro. In
this presentation, we are going to talk a little about
what we have learned to date with
clinical management, since we have been
working with these interns since the
beginning of the  epidemic in my country your
work in brazil rio de janeiro and
well I have no conflict of
interest for this presentation we have
learned a lot from what science
teaches us and this is a very
classic slide of the care that has been
taken with the con  the so-called
Spanish flu from the beginning of the last century
so I say these personal care
to draw attention to the fact
that history always teaches us so
care such as using
masks and not making crowds of
people are care that comes from
history even  long before the
Spanish flu and also spoke of the
great plague
of 14th century cinema where it is also
recommended  In the other thing that we have
understood the origin, Doctor Navarro has
explained very well what is
given to him and for us who know China
very well I have personally seen
several of these fish markets without a
market that are not only for fish
but also for  animals that are dead
comfortable mortars like other animals
that remain alive and dead all mixed up
and it is very clear and the birds that are
living in millions in very large groups
in caves and in closed places are
surely a very easy source of inflection
The other thing to be understood is
that we are talking about something that
we have known about for less than nine months in
the West, at least in our countries,
and we already have this morning, I was
looking again, and we have more than 35,000
papers published on all
matters related to
kobe's disease of 19 so it's something we don't
even realize everything we
have to read and learn what we
know from others without
recent viral respiratory dromes is
important because three of the coronary
causes of severe respiratory infections
and we remember very
well the sat of the first sarzkozy
identified in 2002 as the
etiological agent of the
severe acute respiratory epidemic lammert
ellmers sorry that was identified in
the  middle east in rage with the
etiological agent of the
middle east syndrome that is why there is this name and
finally to be with two who from my
point of view could be called
differently like the circus once today
we know to date here in the great  The
great clinical discovery, let's say, from my
point of view, is the phenomenon of
an inflammatory nature by which
the disease eaten by
that 9 is characterized. It could be calmly called
from circuses with the new virus.
Doctor Navarro has explained himself well. There is
a very great homology between  the whole
family of the crowned, which
probably explains these crossed immunities
Children in particular present and
protect themselves in a certain way due to the
very great homology that exists between the
different viruses of the corona family.
At the beginning of April of this
year,
where the chronology of
what happened in the province
of Agujas was presented, lest those who in
December of December 1 did not
present the known cases of
later until January when the market
all the jan markets have been
closed with the epidemiological alert and
from the clinical point of view as
we understand we continue to understand the
disease I would call them a
biphasic disease, that is, when the
response to the first phase of the call
broke out when the viral
viral response  Forgiveness is presented in a
very clear way with
constitutional symptoms and eventually fever
dry cough diarrhea and  eventually, from the
laboratory point of view, some info had
some damage to the
coagulopathy but that is still followed by
the so-called inflammatory phase,
that is, at the end of the 56 days the
patient enters then and it is the moment
where the lack of air and hypoxia
the radiological abnormalities as
we will see in the
following slides and the patient can
therefore return for the so-called
severe respiratory syndrome with shock that with the
presence of
inflammatory markers of which
interleukin interleukin se and
pcr  the dimers, the troponins or the
markers but as
inflammatory markers that generate some
clinical decisions the interior shin 6
is the most important and in this sense
several potential therapies have appeared
and of these I would say what
I would personally call the drugs
of hope
have  been chloroquine and hydroxy
chloroquine and in the first works
published by the groups s  in feces and
that later it was shown in a society
a use of drugs that is not
useful for any form of kobe 19
for free form but also for
moderate forms and now what remains
only to answer is if it would
eventually have any use in the
very early moment of the disease at
the moment of use probably a little
I would say arbitrary since it is not possible to
detect the symptoms and the symptoms very
early and we know that there is transmission and
even among people who do not have
any
symptoms receiving on the other hand  It is a
new antiviral that has shown in the
North American study a
positive result in terms of
reducing the time in which the
patient remains intensive inter afoot,
that is, this seems to reduce little by 4
but represents a lot on the other hand
because the cost  of having a patient
under intensive care is very high and
also decreases and therefore
intervenes on the morbidity of these
patients.  However, it does not seem to me that patients
want to decide on an antiviral that
has arrived to change the landscape
of Lakovic's treatment scenario 19
I think that it will be a Hamas antiviral and that
it will probably not be a long-
lasting therapy and on the other point they are
what to do  in phase iii more let's say
inflammatory of these patients where
there is, I am going to comment again
on the biological anti-inflammatories,
the corticosteroids and the transfer of
plasma from patients of people like you
mentioned on the timeline the same timeline
that has published what I knew they had been
published by the first works is
the lancet of May at the beginning of
this May where the evolution on the island is shown
and what is on average and the
average in terms of days for the
patient to present his evolution and the
majority of  the patients present
severe acute respiratory syndrome or
sara at the moment more or less on
day 9 day 10 return, that is, when the
patient  The phase is clearly
inflammatory, where
most of the cases have been presented,
which calls attention and is
important for us clinicians
over time, for a long time, for which the patient
remains under intensive therapy,
that is,  It is different, for example, for
us pulmonologists who are
used to severe pneumonia
with patients under mechanical ventilation,
but these patients remain for a
long time, they have to perform a
tracheostomy many times and
still remain under mechanical ventilation.
The first works have also
commented on what  In
inflammatory terms, it is passed where
each one of the
treatment blocks of the attempts at
therapies that have been tried for
these patients would enter, and I would say that we
do not yet have what would be called a
silver bullet, that is, an association of  a
perfect antiviral and a
perfect anti-inflammatory and
still lacking  It would still take the definition
of what would be the most
precious moment for those who are associated with
drugs to work,
that is, in this sense, I would say here what we
have to respond to even under the
clinical rays that are developing
in the world that is  we can find the
right moment when the patient goes
from ease to the
inflammatory phase where then we could
effectively act with an antiviral
1 or 2 antiviral and an anti-inflammatory of
a biological nature to
act this would be something to be answered
in the other thing would be the  transfer
of plasma from patients as a less center
what we are doing in my country in
brazil on a regular basis and the
americans are going to publish the experience
of new york very very soon with
practically 60,000 patients who have
been treated with plasma from comales when
this is  would justify it is explained that is
a very uninteresting work
published in later defining the
cor  current c9 as not as a disease
or with atypical pneumonia as how it
has emerged in the world and how it has arrived
in the West but as a
stormy disease that is something
that has its evolution marked by the
releases of highly toxic cytokines
doing is  Let's say this immunobiological war
between the patient himself,
that is, not only the lungs, but
Lolo, and in the liver, the kidneys, the
intestines, the brain, the eyes in the
nose, because 81 84 85 percent of the
patients lose their sense of smell, they lose their
palate.  taste because the
olfactory bulb is rapidly and very early
compromised by the virus and so it is
very frequent that we make a diagnosis of
these patients only when and right
now they present almost
no symptoms but nevertheless they
complain that they have lost their ability
to taste  and the ability to
feel odors
the pathological point of view this
is also important are the first
published works  icated pneumonias
by horsemen showing the
histological damages demonstrating above all the
deposit of proteins of protein exudate
in the spaces at
ares level and this would also explain with
the endothelin caused and the thrombi in s
of which lakovic are strongly characterized
19 Much of the
hypoxia would be explained if said silent ones that have
surely made us lose many
patients at least in my
experiences at the beginning when we did not
know from this let's say this
pathogenesis of the thrombogenic capacity
of the virus disease and
therefore we would have to  very early wide angle
what we do today in
our work routines in
a very
classic way and I think we all do it
this is a work also published
days ago in the euro think lathe
showing that cob index 9 is
ultimately a disease  endothelial, that is,
he called it endothelin, that is,
everything is characterized by the presence of
factors of three thrombogenic factors
of cytokines that act as if
inflammatory toxins causing damage to the
intima wall of the arteries and also of the
veins causing what we would call
and that is very well defined as
'a dot ellipsis from the point of view
This could be explained by the fact that many
patients who have been cured of
pneumonia come out of mechanical ventilation
but nevertheless remain with
very strong damage with renal failure
and many times, as sequelae, they
remain on hemodialysis. We have
many patients who have come out of a
long stay in  intensive therapy and
who nevertheless continue to
need hemodialysis and this is very sad is
the very sad side of the disease in
terms of involution of
clinical evolution of new these are works already
published a few months ago showing
trying to demonstrate and cross what are
clinical symptoms  the number of days
on which one of these can occur and on
the cl  Ase of the treatment that would be
indicated and this this work is
interesting because here the use of corticosteroids was already shown
a few months ago
and those
you must note that we
have in a certain way
renounced a practice that we would have
much to use  especially
methylprednisolone, even
prednisone instead of dexamethasone, as
has been shown by the large
English study that showed a real interference with
the positive result in
reducing mortality from kobe 19 comparing
very large, very large groups of
patients with  2,000 patients and so
what I mean by this here
we may have made
mistakes by not using the experience
we had for a long time with the
use of corticosteroids,
especially in the advanced phases with sara
in patients with
acute respiratory failure  has also been published
a work that seems to me very
seminal that was published  At the same
time, at the end of May,
I did a meta-analysis of the
efficacy and safety of the use of
corticosteroids in cob and from that 9 emptied
in the best evidence already compared
for other infections you coronavirus
for lakovic syndromes 19  and
also for
severe community-acquired pneumonia, this is a study
that I strongly recommend that you
study because it is a very
well-done meta-analysis in the study. Again, the
presence of corticosteroids would be
justified in all the cases of Kobe
19, which  It presents with sara with
adult acute respiratory syndrome and
yet for the
evidence of the use of
corticosteroids would not be as useful for the cases of kobe 19
that does not have sara, however it would not be
the evidence is considered more
more let's say
weaker  strong
the other thing that is important in the
management term is to understand the
control measures called non-
pharmacological, that is, we know that the
l  The isolation, the
social distancing, the use of masks,
all of this contributed a lot so that
our evolution curve and curve,
let's say, has behaved in a
better or less dramatic way than it
would have if we had not
used the non-pharmacological measures,
so the impact
of the measures is one in an
epidemic or a pandemic surely
reduces a lot by reducing
social contact surely resulted in
more less dramatic data what we have
seen in our countries
that we know about the acute syndrome of
the pictures of sara
and lakovic 19 that  It is also an
interesting work published in the lancet and that
speaks for the first time of what we
would call what would be the sequelae and
this is part of the great
learning curve that we have
developed in the last
nine months, let's say what I would call help  one of
a pregnancy and that we need to reach the
end, that is, here in this work
p  Published since February 2020,
the presence of some cases was already observed
that would show for the first time the
presence of the intervention figures
of pulmonary arms ago and today we know that in
Brazil we have a group a number of
patients that is not small that they
were in  mechanical ventilation for
a longer time and that present
books is pulmonary in need of
pulmonary rehabilitation, however
we still do not have the experience that we
know has been
in some other countries with the
use of antipsychotics such as
la virgen and dona and lanín gives you life  In
small groups of patients
we still do not have this experience
but we know that they are already under evolution
in some places in terms
of radiological evolution. These
are also very works, let's say that they have already
become classic, showing the presence
of consolidations and the
definition of  a pattern that is the
glass pattern of frosted glass as we call it
in patients with  committees of 9 I am
showing the presence and the proportion
of patients in the days and the evolution
between 35 days and him to the great evolution
that occurs in patients in the phase of
said classic and clear inflammatory
from the clinical point of view
this is a  normal tomography with
patients with areas of bronchopneumonia
that will evolve
into these forms, which are what I
would call the different patterns, there are
many, these are just a few
cases that have been done so
that we can see why
radiologists and radiologists have  taught
how they define the proportions, that is,
the cases that have, for example, like
this, 25-30 percent of
lung involvement, most of the time,
this finding is consistent
with a clinical form called non-serious, and
yet the patients who present
more  of 50% lung involvement alone
are the cases that most of the
times the volume for
mechanical ventilation and need for te
intensive care this is a classic evolution
of a patient to a 56-year-
old woman with glass with these capacities and
who flew and in a
very classic way in patients
with severe pneumonia
that is another case of a patient who goes
with the  evolution of mechanical ventilation
and another classic case with compromise of
practically 70-80% of the lungs,
these are classic cases where the
use of corticosteroids and this
is the work to which I was referring recently,
on the efficacy and safety of the
use of corticosteroids in  kobe ​​19 dumped in
evidence and here showing to test
the works using the degree system
of definition of consistency between the
data the use and that is an example
of the use of corticosteroids in
mortality by patients who present a
discomfort or respiratory syndrome in
adults  and in patients without coronary,
showing that the use of
corticosteroids had very clear evidence
for their use.  tion, that is, this is
this meta-analysis clearly recommends
the use of corticosteroids in
all patients with kobe 19 but who also
have the presence
of adult respiratory bewilderment syndrome. In summary, I would say here
between well between the network and those
discovered  and disappointments in this almost
nine months would be in the first place as
I mentioned and chloroquine and hydroxy
chloroquine the known antivirals that
are still part of the so-
called multinational
solidarity study that is canceled and
financed by the or more the use of
hostage to decide that it still needs  be better
validated because the response to
decrease the time of
intensive care is the only one that we
have here to date, yes it seems very
important to me,
knowing that cob and 19 is a
viral disease that concurs with a strong
thrombus determinant at that time  the
early use of anticoagulant that
is the couple and in the full in the
patients that  continue to be more severe or
then new
oral anticoagulants such as Havana pizza and its
correlates could be
used orally for moderately
severe cases once the patient
presents
significant alterations in markers such as
dinner troponin and pcr t
the antibiotics have  been also
optimized as it would be said for cases
where there is evidence that the patient,
especially for those hospitalized
who have presentation of
bacterial infection secondary to the
initial viral disease, the use of
corticosteroids surely the
English work on dexamethasone has
surely shown in the  The first real given with
a large number, however, I was referring to
patients who have had a decrease in
their mortality,
so the other thing to be discovered,
let's say, is the prone position, the prone position,
and even the active one, that is,
in patients who are not under
intubation.  but that having
moderate forms can  being stimulated
makes us stay many hours or a few hours
a day in the prone position the other
discovered or rediscovered as it was
called is non-invasive ventilation
surely incubation
is not something we practice anymore this is
something that at the beginning when the
disease reached us  Many of
us have in fact, but it has been
shown that non-invasive ventilation
optimized with the use of oxygen through
high-flow catheters is something that
can surely interfere with the
evolution, greatly reducing the
morbidity of these patients and, like him,
let's say, prospectively.  I would speak about
the transfer of convalescent plasma,
this is something that we are
going to see because of the work that is about to
be published by the
New York experience that has treated thousands of
patients and finally what would be
called respiratory and neurological sequelae.
We have seen patients  with neuropathy is
that it remains for a long time. I
personally have had com  or 19 and I still
have peripheral neuropathy but
after 3 months and also finally
the sequelae of these vascular
we have seen in a dramatic way
is that it has even
needed amputations of the toes
etc. in conclusion what we learned
that uses the good
Intensive care practices is the least to see better
clinical management to reduce
morbidity and mortality and the best example of
this is like countries in Germany where
no medicine was used
in a tentative way, let's say
it was the good
intensive care practices that have saved and  which has
maintained the very positive data from
that country that early intubation is not
always necessary that the optimization
of non-invasive ventilation with
low-flow or high-flux oxygen or
with masks of the Jaume el más cara type
of full face can surely solve
many cases use corticosteroids in
clearly inflamed patients
lung ventilation  always be protective
with the prone position even in
non-serious patients early anticoagulation
according to the age of
the laboratory markers as I
mention it and use the transfer
of convalescent plasma
this is an example is a young colleague from
here in Rio who has  He had a
very serious new meal that he has
recovered and that he has been the first
plasma donor in our city
just to show you and
I also want to mention the first little
work published by colleagues in
cinemas with five patients that
this school has received for  the first publication
and now surely we will have others
including the Brazilian ones we know to be
optimistic I don't believe what we have to
prepare for is to treat what this
slide calls the fourth wave which
would be the sequelae including the
psychic sequelae of the patients we have had
a number  very large number of patients here
in my country at least and of all that
we have read even and  In the
non-scientific press, which has shown a
higher incidence of psychiatric cases
and even deaths by suicide in
all our countries than currents
of long-term
social distancing of
elderly people who live alone and who
finds no more reason then
something that  I would say there is no need to be
optimistic, that would be my answer to
date, we do not know the strength and duration
of immunity, that is something that
will still have to be answered, Dr. Navarros,
and to comment a little on the diagnosis of
this response and precisely the
protection ratio  conferred by
the vaccines that are about to arrive,
we understand that the maximum protection that
will be provided by the vaccines will be
from 60 to 60 percent, which is a
little above what, for
example, regulatory bodies such as Asia and
America do not consider justifiable
as  vaccine but that has added to the
community immunity we can
surely reach intercept the chain  In the
transmission of the virus,
we do not know why some people
diagnosed as fully
recovered from the virus are
positive if Dr. Navarro
still mentions this fact and what
would be the rate of susceptibility and the rate
of reflection that we should expect
personally, I think that  There will be
reflection, but it will be in very rare cases
rather than eventual and finally we
do not know why some
recovered patients maintain low levels
of antibodies, those would be the questions
and I would end by saying that we still have
much more questions than
answers regarding
Does anyone remember that four people were
effectively infected in the world, we
do not know all the consequences and we do not know
all the risk factors and their
risk tests and with that I would end and I
would be at your disposal for any
questions thank you very much
now we will start the peace
question  Please, we will
respond to
as many as are included in them.
I am not aware of the p  that there is a
perfectly defined algorithm because as far
as I know the
new generation antigen detection tests
are still being evaluated if there is a draft
that would foreseeably become a
protocol or not as far as I know at
least in Spain- we are already working
now  Even with the integration of the
antigen detection test, the
diagnostic algorithms, while things do not
change, the species of this
test of choice, of this there is
no doubt
and little more likely, the
antigen detection test can replace
the PCR if in care  Primary care or in the
emergency room, it would be especially important
if we were able to demonstrate that a
negative antigen, even though the PCR is
positive, corresponds to a stage or
infectivity status.
possible to isolate the
virus therefore the patient is
contagious in people who are
denying you  atives by antigen the
workload with the hospital to the test and that
will not be less
this is my vision with regard
to geological tests some
can be used as auxiliaries but
I do not think they should be
used exclusively for diagnosis of course  from
kobe
thank you very much
one last question
could you elaborate a little more on your
opinion
for the screening
I am in favor of using
it systematically to
spin large populations unless there is
a good reason and I am not aware that it
has been proven that  real because when
you refer to massive screaming, for
example, you are referring to if you have
populations in high-incidence areas,
for example,
I am not aware that it has been
proven that these strategies lead
to local control, at least that is the
impression I get  I have but perhaps the
evidence in the culture indicates the
opposite, for example we have
now seen ourselves in the position  Whether or
not the teachers and professors of schools
and universities are involved in the return of
children or university students to discover
universities, this is an
issue that has caused a lot of controversy
in my country and, well, different
autonomous communities have opted for different
strategies in  The ones that we have
defended is that in an
open compartment such as a school or
a university, as has been pointed out, it is
a university, it does not make much sense
to carry out a PCR systematically
in one go. Perhaps it would be debatable to
do it systematically repeatedly
every  certain time, but I am afraid that
this is not viable from the logistical economic point of view
, therefore a single
PCR to groups of this nature so
numerous in a system that is not
watertight the children enter assembling the
school the processes enter they are in the
school the  same
university professors doesn't seem to make much
sense - no I don't have the feeling
that it doesn't  be sure that there
is scientific evidence to support the use of
this strategy I insist on massive ceres
as they are called at a single moment
not repetitively not repetitively
at specific times this is the
impression I have
doctor margaret a question
for based  In your experience,
what have been the most frequent sequelae
of mild symptoms? What we have seen
are the majority of patients
have no sequelae and the
mild to moderate forms would cry. What we have
seen is a kind of
respiratory hyperreactivity as if the patient, for
example,  He had some degree of not
asthma but pulmonary responsibility
and some degree of peripheral neuropathy
and we have seen and we have also seen it is
to be seen patients who continue
for a long time without taste without palate
and without the ability to feel smells
and  this, this issue, we have seen
patients 34 months after being cured, but
we understand that this will come back if  at
some point
thank you very much and one last question
the criteria for the use of the
plan would surely be what
seems to be a consensus we still need to
have the results of the
patients controlled and compared with
another group but here
we do not apply it and this is more  Or less
consensual with what they are doing in
Europe, for example, for seriously ill patients
who present
very, very large inflammatory phenomena who are under
intensive therapy, then only in these
cases are we using it, but
nevertheless I would say that in the transfer
of convalescent plasma you can be
an alternative even for
non-serious cases that are not under
mechanical ventilation but are hospitalized
with moderate forms but with
clinical confusion and with the presence,
for example, of very high interleukin 6
added to other inflammatory markers
makes me again doctor
[Music
]  would like to thank the water
for accompanying us
questions to  those that we did not have
presents during the period
can be seen on demand even
by email
we will share this email